hello world I have great news I plucked
that weird white hair out that came out
of nowhere I didn't notice that until I
was editing and I was like no way I'm
refilling that whole video so I don't
know what's gonna pop up in this video
it's gonna drive you and me nuts when I
edit but we'll see but hopefully you've
played the last of us two at this point
or you don't care about spoilers this is
my last of us - spoiler talk that as a
spoiler warning if you don't want
spoilers if you weren't on the internet
for the past weeks and you don't know
what the spoilers are at this point well
I'm gonna talk about him here that's
your one and only warning okay spoiler
warnings done you know what's funny cuz
I never saw any trailers for the Last of
Us to pass the teaser trailer the point
is and my video where I was talking
about the teaser trailer someone was
like have you heard the rumor that maybe
Joel's dead and that he wasn't actually
there it was just le imagining him and I
was like well that would be stupid they
wouldn't do that lo and behold so yeah
pretty early on in the Last of Us - Joel
dies it's just a golf club to the head
just BAM Abby kills him Abby definitely
has an axe to grind against this guy and
now Ellie's out there on her quest for
her revenge and yeah when Ellie's story
comes to a head she meets Abby I was
like you killed all my friends and then
now you play as Abby and now you're
leading up to that point so both stories
are gonna converge which really I'm not
alone that was just tough for everybody
it's as much as it's like Oh perspective
villains and heroes is the matter
perspective which is pretty much the
theme of Captain America Civil War for
the first few hours of playing as Abby I
was just like I don't care you killed
Joe which I know joel is no saint and he
was never Illustrated to be he was
always very flawed you knew he was a
villain to something you knew he did
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] you saw that in the
Last of Us one when that dude comes out
in front of their vehicle he's like all
I'm hurt and Joel's like he ain't even
hurt tries to drive right through him
there's a big old fight after the fight
Ellie it's like how'd you know that and
Joe's like with all done stuff like that
I've done stuff like that right there
you're like whoa Joel's done some dark
[ __ ] everybody in the zombie apocalypse
is an [ __ ] to somebody that's just
kind of I'm not saying dead I'm saying
no matter who you are you're an [ __ ]
to somebody there's somebody out there
who thinks you're an [ __ ] people if
they think I'm an [ __ ] just some
thing you either said did whatever we're
all an [ __ ] to somebody so in the
world that's really kill or be killed
life and death I feel like those grudges
would be well yeah but I want that
person dead that's just kind of how
zombie apocalypse works like the old
adage goes you either die a hero or you
live long enough to see things more
clearly I mean even Bach the Ferengi
wanted revenge against Jean Luc Picard
because he blames jean-luc Picard for
his kids death so I mean that's right
there
Picard is a villain to someone else and
then shortly after that Picard was
canceled and thrown out of Starfleet
after Twitter found out that he cheated
on us again at the dom-jot table when he
was a cadet didn't happen but totally
would happen oh now I'm laughing at all
the stories you could make about good
guys who were bad guys to someone else
you know imagine a Star Wars story where
this person's going after wedge and
Lando and he kills legend land oh just
bludgeons them with a pipe or a galactic
golf club if someone's like why'd you do
it he's like because my dad was an
independent contractor on the second
Death Star he was just a construction
guy working on it and wedge and lambda
blew it up they're monsters I tell you
monsters and the point of this is I feel
like The Last of Us two is one of those
all your eggs are in one basket kind of
scenario you know like the whole thing
rests on the premise the fact that after
Joel is killed and Ellie is just lining
the path with bodies she's crawling over
these dead bodies she's creating to get
to her goal to get to her prey and then
the flip happens and you play as a B and
a B is humanized it all rests on the
premise that that sticks the landing for
you because if it doesn't the whole
thing just kind of crumbles like a house
of cards really the game doesn't have
any other tricks up its sleeve it all
rests on that fun stealth kill gameplay
sure but in terms of impact it all rests
on that and that's what I mean when I
say I think I said this in my spoiler
free review I know I went into more
detail and then I cut that out as like I
mean as much as I said you play as a B I
don't want to fly too close to the Sun
when it comes to spoilers which I said
that because that's it is the game it's
kind of like Metal Gear Solid 2 you play
is riding in Metal Gear Solid 2 but in
the end
Ryden still didn't kill snake at the
beginning of the game I would have left
a different taste in my mouth for Metal
Gear Solid 2 but really the Last of Us 2
that we got feels like it should have
been the Last of Us 3 and there should
have been another game that took place
before this game called The Last of Us 2
I mean I don't know exactly the plot I
would go for for this but you know make
it something like if you want Ellie to
go out on her own she does or Ellie and
Joel go out there on their own you see
more of you know the factions out there
that you kind of saw with Abby but
geographically speaking doesn't take
place in Seattle yet because that will
be in the Last of Us 3 will say Joel and
Ellie are mercenaries in this one
faction that there's like hey help us
out with this other faction will give
you a spice of Arrakis all right we need
some spice the spice must flow ok let's
go do it let's do this job so they're
going they're doing the job and you get
wrapped up with these other factions and
you know it's an interesting
post-apocalyptic world and you can have
interesting lore I'm just worried
vomiting you know spend some time
fleshing it out but the point is they
come across that facility that Ellie
then goes into and she finds the
recording like she did in the flashback
I'm the last of us one left off with
Ellie going was their care and Jill's
like no and then BAM it's over and we're
all like whoa that's a cliffhanger of
what's gonna happen flashback so have
fun getting filled in with a brief
flashback so you could have seen that
happen in the Last of Us - and then
Ellie gets pissed off at Joel and goes
off on her own and then when she goes
off on her own that's when you run
across Abby maybe you can play as both
of them so you get attached to Abby and
make a be awesome be like whoa Abby's
really cool one is after half of the
adventure you had more gameplay with
Joel and Ellie and then the next half of
the gameplay you have Ellie and Abby and
you're bonding with all of them at the
end of the adventure Abby finds out that
Ellie knows Joel and then she's like I
gotta go and they cordially depart and
then Abby goes to her friends she's like
I know where he is and then BAM into the
second game you're like what wait what I
would what does she hate Joel why does
she hate Joel and I just feel like
getting bonded with a character in the
second game who will then kill Joel in
the third game it's a it's more
conflicting that would have messed me up
a lot more because I was like now I'm on
Ellie's side [ __ ] this girl
killjoy I know no saint doesn't matter
Jill showed grouse in the first game and
I got attached to the Joel Ellie dynamic
and the ending of this game it almost
makes sense until it doesn't make sense
I heard there's an original ending where
I didn't look into it too much the
endings it's making sense I mean Ellie
doesn't get her revenge but she still
has a life you know she has a good life
she has a girlfriend
her girlfriend's kid she's a stepmom
they're on a farm little sheep it all
looks like it works out and Tommy's like
hey we found her we found Abby and Ellie
has PTSD she's like I gotta go find her
and face her again after we just kind of
agreed she was like don't ever let me
see you again
and you're like all right we're parting
ways now I'm gonna go find her and we're
gonna part ways again but I feel like it
tried to be like pulp fiction where you
got two enemies and someone was in a
really shitty situation it's like we're
gonna go our separate ways well after we
fight and then we're gonna go our
separate ways I heard there was an
original ending and I assume it's the
original ending as Ellie actually does
kill a bee I feel like that would have
been better because after Ellie doesn't
kill a bee and then has her life and
then goes and doesn't kill a bee again
she goes back missing a couple fingers
and definitely doesn't have that life
anymore like her girlfriend has left
with the kid and everything I just
personally feel like it would have been
better not optimal but better if she did
kill a bee and then went back and same
scenario everyone's gone so I was like
you got your revenge but at what cost
point is not only as Neil druckmann a
cat person he's the most jaded person
ever apparently right at the very least
if they just ended it on the farm I feel
like there's a great opportunity there
for Ellie to mentally at least
posthumously reconcile with Joel because
she never got to you know she was like I
hate your guts for killing all the
fireflies and my life could have meant
something but there's no cure now but
I'll get to that in a second but now she
has a kid with the woman she loves and I
just does she not understand now come on
I feel like when she's looking at that
kid she could be like I totally get it
because I couldn't I couldn't just leave
this
to die I feel like she can understand
that now but the game never gave me that
I never got the feeling that she
understood and made that connection it
is interesting that the point of this
game the reason they have you play as
the person who killed Joel is to
illustrate the power of perspective and
the game never actually leads Ellie to a
point where she understands Joel's
perspective as to why he saved her life
thus there is no cure even after she
becomes a mom it's just a weird thing to
me and when it comes to the Cure that
could have happened that most definitely
did not happen he'll put a stop to that
I get Ellie's anger at that I get the
fact that she feels like her life will
never amount to as much as it could have
if a cure had come from her and she gave
her life for that however I post the
argument Joel was 150 percent in the
right not just personally in saving
Ellie's life but just in terms of
humanity how human beings work and what
a cure would have meant to the ones who
had it know this group of douchebags are
gonna be the only group that has a cure
in a world where that could be very
advantageous and you can hold that over
people and use it as a power play you
think this isn't gonna be a power play
look when it comes to human beings when
it comes to the human race there is a
constant and that constant is whenever
we get something that can help us
whenever we get a new technology our
next order of business is to weaponize
it whether it be the tools that our
ancestors used in the caves gunpowder
nuclear energy or social media it can
help us and after we learn that we
weaponize it always a cure in the
lawless apocalyptic setting of the last
of us would have been no different for
those who have it they're going to use
that to establish themselves as the
greatest force and they're gonna
cherry-pick soldiers and make them
immune and then they're gonna have an
enormous army that's completely immune
and they're just gonna lord over
everyone so yes Ellie when you say my
life could have meant something what you
mean is
your life would have been given to
create a superpower that's far worse
than anything you've ever seen in your
life so yeah you should thank Joel for
doing what he did because he did in fact
help out the world and save your life at
the same time Mike when I saw that
comment when I was like uh killing the
dog sucks people are like well you're
fine with killing humans but not dogs
look this is the math right here we're
going by the math that's the math
because yeah this is an immutable fact
you don't see them [ __ ] each other
over for a goddamn percentage I took
that line from Ellen Ripley it's such a
great line Mary Lee's give us an ending
with a little bit of gratification he
doesn't feel like this gratification in
the ending maybe I'm just a little more
old testament where I'm like duh you get
your revenge it's like the phrase at the
very least you know at the very least
give Ellie X it just it never happens
she never gets any of the very least you
know at the very least have her get her
revenge doesn't happen at the very least
don't have the people she loves leave
her doesn't happen like Ellie's just
she's in the worst spot at the end of
this game it just she doesn't get
anything 20 hours a game played is just
sitting in abandoned house because
everyone left man I'm just holding my
dick alone [ __ ] you cherry on top let me
at least be able to play the guitar nope
guess not can't even play the guitar
quite literally by the end of this game
Ellie would be better off dead requiem
for a dream had a happier ending than
this [ __ ] it just all seems to be done
for the sake of shock like shock and
depressing equals profound and they're
just they're not the same thing you can
have a depressing ass ending that's fine
but at least have it makes sense with
the characters I don't buy that Ellie
would have left the farm in the first
place and after she did I don't buy the
fact that she wouldn't have killed Abby
and the point is I leave you with the
footage this is actually my gameplay
footage when I was playing as Abby and
I'm going to the Ellie boss fight this
is actual gameplay footage of me facing
Ellie for the first time and this is
what I did
yep stood there all right Ellie get your
revenge
one more all right Ellie got her revenge
the end
[Music]